Let's bring
in Democratic Congressman
Adam Schiff of California,
who was a member of the January six
committee. Congressman.
What was your reaction
when you first saw this report
and recommended charges
against 39 people?
Did that number seem high?
Do you did
any of the names
on this list surprise you?
You know, what stood out to me, Jake,
is the fact that the grand jury
really did a diligent effort in that
the vote totals,
you know,
for each defendant really varied.
So when they consider Lindsey Graham,
I think the vote was
something like 13 to seven.
When they looked at one of the
then existing Georgia senators,
it was a different vote count.
The other senator
to get another vote count.
That tells me the grand jurors
took their responsibilities seriously.
They weighed the evidence particular
to each defendant.
It wasn't like you know,
kind of a blanket decision.
That's what they're supposed to do.
And the fact that they recommended
charging Lindsey Graham and by the way,
I think Lindsey
Graham's explanation
doesn't pass the laugh test.
You don't as a senator or House member
or other elected official,
call a secretary of state
in some other state
and try to get them to toss out votes.
That is not the least bit
part of the job description.
And he's lucky not to be indicted.
But here the prosecutor made a decision
that their burden of proof
is a different standard
than the grand jury.
The grand jury decides
if there's probable cause.
But a prosecutor's got to decide,
can I prove this
beyond a reasonable doubt?
And, you know, with the varying
conflicting interpretations of that call,
among other things,
I think the prosecutors
made a rational decision.
You know, it's interesting.
Senator Graham
criticizing
the fact that he was almost charged,
even though he was not.
I mean,
the only witness against him
is a conservative Republican
who endorsed Donald Trump.
And the person
who decided to not prosecute
him is a liberal Democrat
who endorsed Joe Biden.
But be that as it may
I want to tick through the votes
to bring charges and go.
I can mention to think,
you know, Lindsey Graham is an attorney.
I think he was in one of the adjutant
in the JAG Corps in the military.
This is someone who knows
the law,
both as a senator,
as a practicing lawyer.
He knows where the line is
and not to cross the line.
He shouldn't have been anywhere
near the line.
So, as I said,
I think he's gotten off lucky here.
And I do think
even though he's not been indicted,
it will be a deterrent.
To other members of Congress
not to meddle, not to approach the line
when it comes to suggesting votes
ought to be tossed out
to favor your candidate.
I want to tick through the votes
to bring charges or not bring charges
against some of Trump's
top allies,
Michael Flynn,
Boris Epshteyn and Cleta Mitchell.
The grand jury voted the same way
for all three of them.
20 said to bring yet
to bring votes to bring charges, rather.
24.
Flynn Epstein and Clayton Mitchell,
one for each one of them said no.
And zero abstained.
That's nearly unanimous for all three.
Yet charges
were not brought
against any one of these individuals.
What do you make of that?
You know, it could be,
as you
were discussing earlier,
that some of these people
have decided to cooperate
in the case of the folks
you just mentioned.
That seems, though,
very unlikely
These are some hardcore people.
My guess is that the prosecutors
just made a different judgment
about what were the
what was the availability
of the legal defenses
and they took a different view of things
than the grand jurors.
That is not at all uncommon.
And to me,
it is sound prosecutorial discretion
They're going to have a hard
enough case as it is,
you know, given
all the
the public attention around this case.
And so I think
going with their strongest charges
against those,
you have the best proof
to get convictions
is the right approach for prosecutors
and also charges, obviously,
and ultimately not brought against
Lindsey Graham Perdue and Kelly Loeffler.
Why not do you think
do you
think finally Wallace was
was worried about being perceived
as being too political?
Do you think
it was just a matter of evidence
My guess is that it was a matter
of the evidence and,
you know, their assessment
of what they could prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
in the case of Graham.
You have some ambiguity
about what took place during that call.
You don't have the definitive record
that we did
with Trump's call with Raffensperger And
and so I think it's a sensible judgment,
the fact that the grand jurors themselves
were divided.
If the vote for four grand, for
example, was 13 to seven,
that doesn't smell a lot of success
when you go to the higher
standard of proof
in a criminal courtroom
where if you have even a single juror
say, no,
you don't get the unanimous verdict
that you need.
So I think rational judgments
and this case is of such great importance
because it goes to the heart
of our peaceful transfer of power.
We're you know
as members of the January six
committee were,
you know,
very proud of the work
we did to bring these facts
before the American people,
to force prosecutors to confront them
and make these difficult decisions.
We did accountability
as much as we could.
It's up to prosecutors to bring justice.
Yeah.
One other
note on
Lindsey Graham
is that
it's because Lindsey Graham denied
what what Raffensperger said.
He told him that Raffensperger
recorded the call with Trump.
So Donald Trump
might have Lindsey Graham
to thank for his Georgia indictment.
Congressman Adam Schiff, thanks so much.